تحذير شديد اللهجه من طهران لحكومه طالبان
بسبب خلاف الدولتين على توزيع حصص المياه
بينهما الرئيس ابراهيم رئيس قال ان ايران
ستعمل اي وسيله متاحه للحصول على حقها في
المياه بعد اغلاق طالبان لسد كجكي في
الواقع هذا النهر واقع تحديدا على نهرها
المد على الحدود بين الدولتين على الجانب
الاخر تقول طالبان ان منع ايصال المياه
الى ايران سببه قله توفر المياه في نهرها
المند والجفاف وانعدام الامطار على
المناطق الغربيه لافغانستان يتمحور الخلاف
الايراني الافغاني بشان الماء اساسا حول
هذا النهد نهر الذي ينبع من جبال هندو كوش
شمال شرقي افغانستان ويصب في بحيره هامون
الايرانيه ويعد اهم موارد الماء في
البلدين في سنه 1973
ابرمت الحكومتان الايرانيه والافغانيه
اتفاقيه اقتسام مياه المن وحددت حصه ايران
الثانويه ب 820 مليون متر مكعب من المياه
تحوز افغانستان 57 مليار متر مكعب من
متوسط الانهار السنوي ولكنها تستهلك اقل
من ثلث هذا الرقم ويذهب
الباقي من المياه الى دول الجوار مثل
باكستان وايران ودول اسيا الوسطى تقول
ايران انها خسرت العام الماضي اربعه
ملايين متر مكعب من المياه في حين تراجع
منسوب المياه في الانهار الافغانيه بسبب
الجفاف وايضا قله هطول الامطار وتطالب
طهران باعاده النظر في الاتفاقيه التي
وقعت بين البلدين لكن الحكومات الافغانيه
المتتاليه ترفض هذا الطلب الايراني وتقول
ان الاتفاقيه شامله وتنص على وضع المياه
طيله فصول السنه وتطالب طهرا بالالتزام
بها
وفقا للمعاهده هذا حق طبيعي لايران واذا
لزم الامر
افضل اجبار ذلك القسم من الهيئه الحاكمه
الافغانيه الذي لا يتعاون بشان منح ايران
حصتها المائيه من نهرها
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات